The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Doesn't
to run Flash Player.
So I had to run them on Chrome.
All right, so let's move
on to our second chapter.
And hopefully, in
this chapter, you
will feel a little
better if you felt
like it was going a bit
fast in the first chapter.
And the main reason we
actually went fast, especially
in terms of
confidence intervals.
Some of you came
and asked me what
you mean by this is a
confidence interval?
What does it mean that
it's not happening
in there with probability
95%, et cetera?
I just went really
fast so that you
could see why I didn't want
to give you a first week doing
probability only
without understanding
what the statistical
context for it was.
So hopefully, all
these things that we've
done in terms of
probability, you actually
know why we've been doing them.
And so we're basically going
to go back to what we're doing,
maybe start with some
statistical setup.
But the goal of this
lecture is really
going to go back again to
what we've seen from a purely
statistical perspective.
All right?
So the first thing
we're going to do
is explain why we're doing
statistical modeling, right?
So in practice,
if you have data,
if you observe a
bunch of points--
in here, I gave you some
numbers, for example.
So here's the partial data sets
with the number of siblings,
including self, that were
collected from college
students a few years back.
So I was teaching
a class like yours
and actually asked
students to go
and fill out some Google form
and tell me a bunch of things.
And one of the questions
was, including yourself,
how many siblings do you have?
And so they gave me this
list of numbers, right?
And there's many ways I can
think of this list of numbers,
right?
I could think of it as being
just a discrete distribution
on the set of
numbers between 1--
I know there's not going to be
an answer which is less than 1,
unless, well, someone doesn't
understand the question.
But all the answers I should
get are positive integers--
1, 2, 3, et cetera.
And there probably
is an upper bound,
but I don't know it
on the top of my head.
So maybe I should say 100.
Maybe I should say 15.
It depends, right?
And so I think the largest
number I got for this was 6.
All right?
So here you can see you have
pretty standard families,
you know, lots of
1s, 2s, and 3s.
What statistical
modeling is doing
is to try to compress
this information that I
could actually describe
in a very naive way.
So let's start with the
basic usual statistical set
up, right?
So I will start with many
of the boards that look
like x1, xn, random variables.
And what I'm going to
assume, as we said typically
is that those guys are IID.
And they have some
distribution, all right?
So they all share the
same distribution.
And the fact that their IID
is so that I can actually
do statistics.
Statistics means looking at
the global averaging thing
so that I can actually
get a sense of what
the global behavior is
for the population, right?
If I start assuming that those
things are not identically
distributed-- they all
live on their own--
that my sequence of number
is your number of siblings--
the shoe size of this person--
the depth of the
Charles River, and I
start measuring
a bunch of stuff.
There's nothing I can
actually get together.
I need to have something
that's cohesive.
And so here, I collected
some data that was cohesive.
And so the goal here--
the first thing is to say what
is the distribution that I
actually have here, right?
So I could actually
be very general.
I could just say at
some distribution p.
And let's so those are random
variables, not random vectors,
right?
I could collect entire
vectors about students,
but let's say those are
just random variables.
And so now I can start
making assumptions
on this distribution p, right?
What can I say about
a distribution?
Well, maybe if those
numbers are continues,
for example, I could assume
they have a density--
a probability density function.
That's already an assumption.
Maybe I could start to assume
that they're probability
density function is smooth.
That's another assumption.
Maybe I could actually assume
that it's piecewise constant.
That's even better, right?
And those things make my
life simpler and simpler,
because what I do by making
the successive assumptions is
reducing the degrees of
freedom of the space in which I
am actually searching
the distribution.
And so what we actually
want is to have something
which is small enough
so we can actually
have some averaging going on.
But we also want something
which is big enough
that it can actually express.
It has chances of actually
containing a distribution that
makes sense for us.
So let's start with the
simplest possible example,
which is when the
xi's belong to 0, 1.
And as I said, here,
we don't have a choice.
The distribution of those
guys has to be Bernoulli.
And since they are IID,
they all share the same p.
So that's definitely the
simplest possible thing
I could think of.
They are just Bernoulli p.
And so all I would have to
figure out in this case is p.
And this is the simplest case.
And unsurprisingly, it has
the simplest answer, right?
We will come back
to this example
when we study maximum
likelihood estimators or method
of moments estimators
by method of moments.
But at the end of
the day, the things
that we did-- the
things that we will do
are always the
naive estimator you
would come up with is what
is the proportion of 1.
And this will be, in
pretty much all respects,
the best estimator
you can think of.
All right?
So then we're going to try
to assess this performance.
And we saw how to do that in
the first chapter as well.
So this problem here somehow
is completely understood.
We'll come back to it.
But there's nothing fancy
that is going to happen.
But now, I could have some
more complicated things.
For example, in the example
of the students now,
my xi's belong to the
sequence of integers 1, 2, 3,
et cetera, OK, which is also
denoted by n, maybe without 0
if you want to put
0 in that, right?
So the positive integers.
Or I could actually
just maybe put
some prior knowledge
about how humans
have time to have families.
But maybe some people thought
of their college mates
as being their
brothers and sisters.
And one student would
actually put 465 siblings,
because we're all good friends.
Or maybe they actually think
that all their Facebook
contacts are actually
their siblings.
And so you never know
what's going to happen.
So maybe you want
to account for this,
but maybe you know that
people are reasonable,
and they will actually give
you something like this.
Now intuitively, maybe
you would say, well,
why would you bother
doing this if you're not
really sure about the 20?
But I think that
probably all of you
intuitively guess that this
is probably a good idea
to start putting this
kind of assumption
rather than allowing for any
number in the first place,
because this eventually
will be injected
into the precision
of our estimators.
If I allow anything, it's going
to be more complicated for me
to get an accurate estimator.
If I know that the numbers
are either 1 or 2, then
I'm actually going to be
slightly more accurate as well.
All right?
Because I know that, for
example, somebody put the 5,
I can remove it.
Then it's not going to actually
corrupt with my estimator.
All right, so now,
let's say we actually
agree that we have numbers.
And here I put
seven numbers, OK?
So I just said,
well, let's assume
that the numbers
I'm going to get
are going to be 1 all the way
to say this number that I denote
by larger than or
equal to 7, which
is a placeholder for any
numbers larger than 7, OK?
Because I know
maybe I don't want
to distinguish between people
that have 9 or 25 siblings.
OK, and so now, this
is a distribution
on seven possible values--
the discrete distributions.
And you know from
your probability class
that the way you describe
this distribution
is using the probability
mass function.
OK, or PMF--
So that's how we describe
a discrete distribution.
And the PMF is just a
list of numbers, right?
So as I wrote here, you
have a list of numbers.
And here, you wrote
the possible value
that your random
variable can take.
And here you rate
the probability
that your random variable
takes this value.
So the possible values being 1,
2, 3 all the way to larger than
or equal to 7.
And then I'm trying to
estimate those numbers.
Right?
If I give you those
numbers, at least up to this
you know compression of all
numbers that are equal to 7,
you have the full description
of your distribution.
And that is the ultimate
goal of statistics, right?
The ultimate goal
of statistics is
to say what distribution
your data came from,
because that's basically
the best you're
going to be able to do.
Now admittedly, if I started
looking at the fraction of 1s,
and the fraction of 2s, and
the fraction of 3s, et cetera,
I would actually eventually
get those numbers--
just like looking at
the fraction of 1s
gave me a good estimate for
p in the Bernoulli case,
it would do the same
in this case, right?
It's a pretty intuitive idea.
It's just the law
of large numbers.
Everybody agrees with that?
If I look at the proportion
of 1s, the proportion of 2s,
the proportion of 3s,
that should actually
give me something that gets
closer and closer, as my sample
size increases to what I want.
But the problem is if my
sample size is not huge,
here I have seven
numbers to estimate.
And if I have 20
observations, the ratio
is not really in my favor--
20 observations to estimate
seven parameters-- some of them
are going to be
pretty off, typically
the ones with the large values.
If you have only 20 students,
look at the list of numbers.
I don't know how many numbers
I have, but it probably
is close to 20--
maybe 15 or something.
And so if you look at
this list, nobody's
actually-- nobody has four
or more siblings, right?
There's no such person.
So that means that eventually
from this data set,
my estimates--
so those numbers I denote by
say p1, p2, p3, et cetera--
those estimates p4 hat would be
equal to what from this data?
0, right?
And p5 hat equal to 0 and
p6 hat would be equal to 0.
And p larger than or equal
to 7 hat would be equal to 0.
That would be my estimate
from this data set.
So maybe this is not--
maybe I want to actually
pull some information
from the people who
have less siblings
to try to make a guess,
which is probably
slightly better for the
larger values, right?
It's pretty clear that in
average, there is more than 0--
the proportion of the
population of households
that have four children or
more is definitely more than 0,
all right?
So it means that
my data set is not
representative of
what I'm going to try
to do is to find a model that
tries to use the data they have
for the smaller values that I
can observe and just push it up
to the other ones.
And so what we can do is to
just reduce those parameters
into something
that's understood.
And this is part of the
modeling that I talked about
in the first place.
Now, how do you succinctly
describe a number of something?
Well, one thing that you do
is the Poisson distribution,
right?
Why do Poisson?
There's many reasons.
Again, that's part
of statical modeling.
But once you know that you
have number of something that
can be modeled by a Poisson,
why not try a Poisson, right?
You could just fit a Poisson.
And the Poisson is something
that looks like this.
And I guess you've all seen it.
But if x follows a
Poisson distribution
with parameter lambda,
than the probability
that x is equal to little
x is equal to lambda
to the x over factorial
x e to the minus lambda.
OK?
And if you did the sheet that
I gave you on the first day,
you can check those numbers.
So this is, of course, for x
equals 0, 1, et cetera, right?
So x is in natural integers.
And if you sum from x equals 0
to infinity, this thing you get
is e to the lambda.
And so they cancel,
and you have some
which is equal to 1,
which is indeed a PMF.
But what's key about this PMF
is that it never takes value 0.
Like this thing is
always strictly positive.
So whatever value of lambda
I find from this data
will give me something
that's certainly
more interesting than
just putting the value 0.
But more importantly,
rather than having
to estimate seven parameters
and, as a consequence,
to actually have
to estimate 1, 2,
3, 4 of them being equal to
0, I have only one parameter
to estimate which is lambda.
The problem with doing this
is that now lambda may not
be just something as simple as
computing the average number.
Right?
In this case, it will.
But in many instances,
it's actually not clear
that this parametrization
with lambda that I chose--
I'm going to be able to estimate
lambda just by computing
the average number that I get.
It will be the case.
But if it's not, remember this
example of the exponential
we did in the last lecture--
we could use the delta
method and things
like that to estimate them.
All right, so
here's modeling 101.
So the purpose of
modeling is to restrict
the base of possible
distributions
to a subspace that's actually
plausible, but much simpler
for me to estimate.
So we went from
all distributions
on seven parameters,
which is a large space--
that's a lot of things--
to something which
is just one number.
This number is positive.
Any question about the
purpose of doing this?
OK, so we're going to have to do
a little bit of formalism now.
And so if we want to talk--
this is a statistics classroom.
I'm not going to want to
talk about the Poisson model
specifically every single time.
I'm going to want to talk
about generic models.
And then you're going to build
to plug in your favorite word--
Poisson, binomial,
exponential, uniform--
all these words
that you've seen,
you're going to be
able to plug in there.
But we're just going to
have some generic notations
and some generic terminology
for a statistical model.
All right?
So here is the
formal definition.
So I'm going to go
through it with you.
OK, so the definition is
that of a statistical model.
OK?
Sorry, that's a statistical
experiment, I should say.
So a statistical experiment
is actually just a pair--
E. And that's a set--
and a family of distributions
P theta, where theta ranges
in some set capital theta.
OK?
So I hope you're up to date
with your Greek letters.
So the small theta
is the capital theta.
And enough of us--
I don't have the handwriting.
So if you don't see
something, just ask me.
And so this thing now--
so each of this guy
is a probability distribution.
All right?
So for example, this could be
a Poisson with parameter theta
or a Bernoulli with
parameter theta--
OK, or an exponential
with parameter--
I don't know-- 1 over
theta squared if you want.
OK, but they're just
indexed by theta.
But for each theta,
this completely
describes the distribution.
It could be more complicated.
This theta should be a pair--
could be a pair-- a mu sigma
square.
And that could actually give
you some n mu sigma squared.
OK so anything where
you can actually--
rather than actually giving
you a full distribution,
I can compress into a parameter.
But it could be worse.
It could be this guy here.
Right?
Theta could be p1--
p larger than or equal to 7.
And my distribution could just
be something that has PMF--
p1-- p larger than 7.
That's another parameter.
This one is seven dimensional.
This one is two dimensional.
And all these guys are
just one dimensional.
All these guys are parameters.
Is that clear?
What's important here is that
once they give you theta,
you know exactly all the
probabilities associated
with this random variable.
You know its
distribution perfectly.
So this is the definition.
Is that clear?
Is there a question
about this distribution--
about this definition, sorry?
All right.
So really, the key thing is the
statistical model associated
to a statistical experiments.
OK?
So let's just see some examples.
It's probably just better
because, again, the formalism
is never really clear.
Actually, that's the next slide.
OK, so there's two
things we need to assume.
OK, so the purpose of
a statistical model
is once I estimate
the parameter,
I actually know exactly what
distribution it has, OK?
So it means that I
could potentially
have several
parameters that give me
the same distribution that would
still be fine, because I could
estimate one guy.
Or I could estimate
the other guy.
And I would still recover
the underlying distribution
of my data.
The problem is that this
creates really annoying
theoretical
problems, like things
don't work, the
algorithms won't work,
the guarantees won't work.
And so what we typically
assume is that the model
is so-called well-specified.
Sorry, that's not
well specified.
I'm jumping ahead of myself.
OK, well-specified
means that your data--
the distribution of your data
is actually one of those guys.
OK?
So some vocabulary--
so well-specified
means that for my
observations x,
there exists a theta
in capital theta
such that x follows p sub theta.
I should put a double bar.
OK, so that's what
well-specified means.
So that means that
the distribution
of your actual data is
just one of those guys.
This is a bit strong
of an assumption.
It's strong in the sense that--
I don't know if you've heard of
this sense, which I don't know,
I can tell you who
it's attributed to,
but that probably means
that this person did not
come up with it.
But I said that all models
are wrong, but some of them
are useful.
All right, so all
models are wrong
means that maybe it's not true
that this Poisson distribution
that I assume for the number of
siblings for college students--
maybe that's not
perfectly correct.
Maybe there's a spike
at three, right?
Maybe there's a spike at
one, because you know,
maybe those are slightly
more educated families.
They have less children.
Maybe this is actually
not exactly perfect.
But it's probably good
enough for our purposes.
And when we make
this assumption,
we're actually assuming
that the data really
comes from a Poisson model.
There is a lot of
research that goes on
about misspecified
models and that tells you
how well you're doing
in the model that's
the closest to the
actual distribution.
So that's pretty much it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So my data--
so it's always the
way I denote one
of the generic
observations, right?
So my observations are x1, xn.
And they're IID with
distribution p--
always.
So x is just one of those guys.
I don't want to write x5 or x4.
They're IID.
So they all have the
same distribution.
So OK-- no, no, no.
They're all IID.
So they all have
the same p data.
They'll have the
same p, which means
they'll have the same p data.
So I can pick any one of them.
So I'd just remove the
index just so we're clear.
OK?
So when I write x, I
just mean think of x1.
Right they're an idea.
I can pick whichever I want.
I'm not going to write x1.
It's going to be weird.
OK?
Is that clear?
OK.
So this particular theta is
called the true parameter.
Sometimes since we're going
to want some variable theta,
we might denote it by
theta star as opposed
to theta hat, which is
always our estimator.
But I'll keep it to
be theta for now.
And so the aim of this
physical experiment
is to estimate theta
so that once I actually
plug in theta in the form of
my distribution, for example,
I could plug in theta here.
So theta here was
actually lambda.
So once I estimate this
guy, I would plug it in,
and I would know the probability
that my random variable takes
any value, by just putting the
lambda hat and the lambda hat
here.
OK?
So my goal is going
to be to estimate
this guy so that I can actually
compute those distributions.
But actually, we'll
see, for example,
when we talk about regression
that this parameter actually
has a meaning in many instances.
And so just knowing
the parameter itself
intuitively or say more--
let's say more so than just
computing probabilities,
will actually tell us
something about the process.
For example, we're going
to run linear regression.
And when we do
linear regression,
there's going to be
some coefficients
in the linear regression.
And the value of
this coefficient
is actually telling me what is
the sensitivity of the response
that I'm looking at to
this particular input.
All right?
So just knowing if
this number is larger
or if this number
is small is actually
going to be useful for us
to just look at this guy.
All right?
So there's going to be
some instances where
it's going to be important.
Sometimes we're going to want
to know if this parameter is
larger or smaller than something
or if it's equal to something
or not equal to something.
And those things are also
important-- for example,
if theta actually
measures the true--
right?
So theta is the true unknown
parameter-- true efficacy
of a drug.
OK?
Let's say I want to know what
the true efficacy of a drug is.
And what I'm going to want to
know is maybe it's a score.
Maybe I'm going to want to
know if theta is larger than 2.
Maybe I want to know if theta is
the average number of siblings.
Is this true number
larger than 2 or not?
Right?
Maybe I am interested in knowing
if college students come from--
so maybe from a
sociological perspective,
I'm interested in knowing
if college students come
from households with
more than two children.
All right, so those
can be the questions
that I may ask myself.
I'm going to want to
know maybe theta is going
to be equal to 1/2 or not.
So maybe for a drug
efficacy, is it completely
standard-- maybe for elections.
Is the proportion
of the population
that is going to vote for
this particular candidate
equal to 0.5?
Or is it different from 0.5?
OK, and I can think
of different things.
When I'm talking
about the regression,
I'm going to want to test if
this coefficient is actually
0 or not, because
if it's 0, it means
that the variable that's in
front of it actually goes out.
And so those are
things we're testing.
Actually having this very
specific yes/no answer
is going to give me a huge
intuition or huge understanding
of what's going on in the
phenomenon that I observe.
But actually, since the
questions are so precise,
it's going to be much more--
I'm going to be much better
at answering them rather
than giving you an
estimate for theta
with some confidence around it.
All right, it's sort of the same
principle as trying to reduce.
What you're trying to
do as a statistician
is to inject as much knowledge
about the question and about
the problem that you
can so that the data has
to do a minimal job.
And henceforth, you
actually need less data.
So from now on, we
will always assume--
and this is because this
is an intro stats class--
you will always
assume that theta--
the subset of parameters
is a subset of r to the d.
That means that
theta is a vector
with at most a finite
number of coordinates.
Why do I say this?
Well, this is called
a parametric model.
So it's called a parametric
model or sometimes
parametric statistics.
Actually, we don't really talk
about parametric statistics.
But we talk a lot about
nonparametric statistics
or a non-parametric model.
Can somebody think of a model
which is non-parametric?
For example, in the
siblings example,
if I did not cap the
number of siblings to 7,
but I let this list
go to infinity,
I would have an infinite number
of parameters to estimate.
Very likely, the
last ones would be 0.
But still, I would have an
infinite number of parameters
to estimate.
So this would not be
a parametric model
if I just let this
list of things
to be estimated to be infinite.
But there's other classes
that are actually infinite
and cannot represented
by vectors.
For example, function-- right?
If I tell you my
model, pf, is just
the distribution of x's, the
probability distributions,
that have density f, right?
So what I know is that the
density is non-negative
and that it integrates
to one, right?
That's all I know
about densities.
Well f is not
something you're going
to be able to describe with a
finite number of values, right?
All possible functions
is the huge set.
It's certainly not
representable by 10 numbers.
And so non-parametric
estimation is typically
when you actually want
to parametrize this
by a large class of functions.
And so for example,
histograms is the prime tool
of non-parametric
estimation, because when
you fit a histogram
to data, you're
trying to estimate the
density of your data,
but you're not trying
to represent it
as a finite number of points.
That's really-- I
mean, effectively,
you have to represent it, right?
So you actually truncate
somewhere and just
say those things are
not going to matter.
All right?
But really the key thing is
that this is non-parametric
where you have a potentially
infinite number of parameters.
Whereas we're going to
only talk about finites.
And actually finite in the
overwhelming majority of cases
is going to be 1.
So theta is going to
be a subset of r1.
OK, we're going to be
interested in estimating
one parameter just like
the parameter of a Poisson
or the parameter
of an exponential--
the parameter of Bernoulli.
But for example,
really, we're going
to be interested in
estimating mu and sigma
square for the normal.
So here are some
statistical models.
All right?
So I'm going to go
through them with you.
So if I tell you I observe--
I'm interested in
understanding--
I'm still [INAUDIBLE] I'm
interested in understanding
the proportion of people
who kiss by bending
their head to the right.
And for that, I
collected n observations.
And I'm interested in
making some inference
in the statistical model.
My question to you is, what
is the statistical model?
Well, if you want to read
the statistical model,
you're going to have
to write this E--
oh, sorry, I never
told you what E was.
OK, well actually just
go to the examples,
and then you'll know what E is.
So you're going to have to write
to me an E and a p theta, OK?
So let's start with
the Bernoulli trials.
So this e here is
called the sample space.
And in the normal
people's words,
it just means the space or
the set in which x and--
back to your question, x is
just a generic observation lips.
OK, and hopefully, this is
the smallest you can think of.
OK, so for example,
for Bernoulli trials,
I'm going to observe a
sequence of 0's and 1's.
So my experiment is going to
be-- as written on the board,
is going to be 1, 0, 1.
And then the probability
distributions
are going to be,
well, it's just going
to be the Bernoulli
distributions indexed
by p, right?
So rather than
writing p sub p, I'm
going to write it
as Bernoulli p,
because it's clear what
I mean when I write that.
Is everybody happy?
Actually, I need to
tell you something more.
This is a family
of distributions.
So I need p.
And maybe I don't
want to have to p
that's a value 0, 1, right?
It doesn't make sense.
I would probably not
look at this problem
if I anticipated that everybody
would kiss to the right.
And everybody would
kiss to the left.
So I am going to assume
that p is in 0, 1,
but does not have 0 and 1.
OK?
So that's the statistical
model for a Bernoulli trial.
OK, now the next
one, what do we have?
Exponential.
OK?
OK, so when I have
exponential distributions,
what is the support of the
exponential distribution?
What value is it going to take?
0 to infinity, right?
So what I have is
that my first space
is the value that my
random variables can take.
So its-- well, actually I
can remove the 0 again--
0 to plus infinity.
And then the family
of distributions
that I have are exponential
with parameter lambda.
And again, maybe you've
seen me switching
from p, to lambda, to theta,
to mu, to sigma square.
Honestly you can do
whatever you want.
But its just that it's customary
to have this particular group
of letters.
OK?
And so the parameters
of an exponential
are just positive numbers.
OK?
And that's my exponential model.
What is the third one?
Can somebody tell me?
Poisson, OK?
OK, so Poisson-- is a
Poisson random verbal
discrete or continuous?
Go back to your probability.
All right, so the answer being
the opposite of continuous--
good job.
All right, so it's going to be--
what value can a Poisson take?
All the natural integers, right?
So 0, 1, 2, 3, all
the way to infinity.
We don't have any
control of this.
So I'm going to write
this as n without 0.
I think in the slides,
it's n-star maybe.
Actually, no, you
can take value 0.
I'm sorry.
This actually takes
value 0 quite a lot.
That's typically, in many
instances, actually the mode.
So it's n, and then
I'm going to write it
as Poisson with
parameter-- well,
here it's again
lambda as a parameter.
And lambda can take
any positive value.
OK?
And that's where you can
actually see that the model
that we had for the
siblings-- right?
So let me actually just squeeze
in the siblings model here.
So that was the bad model
that I had in the first place
when I actually kept this.
Let's say we just kept it at 7.
Forget about larger
than or equal to 7.
We just assumed it was 7.
What was our sample space?
We said 7.
So it's 1, 2, to 7, right?
Those were the possible values
that this thing would take.
And then what was my--
what's my parameter space?
So it's going to be
a nightmare write.
But I'm going to write it.
OK, so I'm going to write it as
something like the probability
that x is equal to k
is equal to p sub k.
OK?
And that's going to be for p.
OK, so that's for
all k's, right?
Or for k equal 1 to 7.
And here the index is the
set of parameters p1 to pk.
And I know a little more
about those guys, right?
I know there are going
to be non-negative--
PJ non-negative.
And I know that they sum to 1.
OK, so maybe writing
this, you start
seeing why we like those
Poisson, exponential,
and short notation, because
I actually don't have
to write the PMF of a Poisson.
The Poisson is really just this.
But I call it Poisson
so I don't have
to rewrite this all the time.
And so here, I did not
use a particular form.
So I just have this thing,
and that's what it is.
The set of parameters is the
set of positive numbers of--
p1 to p7, pk--
and sum to 7, right?
And so this as just
a list of numbers
that are non-negative
and sum up to 1.
So that's my parameter space.
OK?
So here that's my theta.
This whole thing here--
this is my capital theta.
OK?
So that's just the
set of parameters
that theta-- the
that theta is allowed to take.
OK, and finally, we're going
to end with the star of all,
and that's the
normal distribution.
And in the normal
distribution, you still
have also some flexibility
in terms of choices,
because then naturally,
the normal distribution
is parametrized by--
the normal distribution is
parametrized by two parameters,
right?
Mean and variance.
So what values can a Gaussian
random variable take?
An entire real line, right?
And the set of
parameters that it
can take it-- so this is going
to be n, mu, sigma square.
And mu is going to be positive.
And stigma square is going--
sorry, m is going to be an r.
And sigma square is
going to be positive.
OK, so again here,
that's the way
you're supposed to write it.
If you really want to
identify what theta is,
well, theta formally is the set
of mu sigma square such that--
well, in r times
0 infinity, right?
That's just to be formal, but
this does the job just fine.
OK?
You don't have to
be super formal.
OK, that's not three.
That's like five.
Actually, I just want
to write another one.
Let's call it 5-bit.
And 5-bit is just Gaussian
with known variants.
And this arises a
lot in labs when
you have measurement error--
when you actually receive
your measurement device.
This thing has been
tested by the manufacturer
so much that it actually comes
in on the side of the box.
It says that the standard
deviation of your measurements
is going to be 0.23.
OK, and actually why you
do this is because we
can brag about accuracy, right?
That's how they sell you
this particular device.
And so you actually know
exactly what sigma square is.
So once you actually get
your data in the lab,
you actually only
have to estimate mu,
because stigma
comes on the label.
So now, what is your
statistical model?
Well, the numbers are
collecting still in r.
But now, the models that I
have is n, mu, sigma squared.
But the parameter space is not
mu, and r, and sigma positive.
It's just mu and r.
And to be a little more
emphatic about this,
this is enough to
describe it, right?
Because if sigma
is the sigma that
was specified by
the manufacturer,
then this is the sigma you want.
But you can actually
write sigma is equal to--
sigma square is equal to
sigma square manufacturer.
Right?
You can just fix it to
be this particular value.
Or maybe you don't want
to write that index that's
the manufacturer.
And so you just say,
well, the sigma--
when I write n
squared what I mean
is the sigma square
from the manufacturer.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
For a particular
measuring device?
You know, you're in a lab, and
you have some measuring device.
I don't know--
something that measures
tensile strength of something.
And it's just going
to measure something.
And it will naturally
make errors.
But it's been tested so
much by the manufacturer
and calibrated by them.
They know it's not
going to be perfect.
But they knew
exactly what error it
was making, because
they've actually tried it
on things for which
they exactly knew
what the tensile strength was.
OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: This?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh,
like that's pointing to--
5 prime?
OK?
And we can come up with
other examples, right?
So for example,
here's another one.
So the names don't
really matter, right?
I call it the siblings model.
But you won't find the siblings
model in the textbook, right?
So I wouldn't worry too much.
But for example, let's say
you have something-- so
let's call it 6.
You have-- I don't know--
a truncated-- and that's the
name I just came up with.
But it's actually not exactly
describing what I want.
But let's say I observe y, which
is the indicator of x larger
than say 5 when x follows some
exponential with parameter
lambda.
OK?
This is what I get to observe.
I only observe if
my waiting time
was more than five
minutes, because I
see somebody coming out
of the Kendall Station
being really upset.
And that's all I record
is I've been waiting
for more than five minutes.
And that's all I get to record.
OK?
That happens a lot.
These are called censored data.
I should probably not
call it truncated,
but this should be censored.
OK?
You see a lot of censored
data when you ask people
how much they make.
They say, well, more
than five figures.
And that's all they
want to tell you.
OK?
And so you see a lot of censored
data in survival analysis,
right?
You are trying to understand
how long your patients are going
to live after some surgery, OK?
And maybe you're not going
to keep people alive,
and you're not
going to actually be
in touch in their family
every day and ask them,
is the guy still alive?
And so what you
can do is just you
ask people maybe five
years after your study
and say, please, come in.
And you will just happen to
have some people say, well, you
know, the person is deceased.
And you will only be able to
know that the person deceased
less than five years ago.
But you only see what
happens after that, OK?
And so this is this
truncated and censored data.
It happens all the
time just because you
don't have the ability
to do better than that.
So this could happen here.
So what is my physical
experiment, right?
So here, I should probably
write this like this,
because I just told you that my
observations are going to be x,
but there is some unknown y.
I will never get to see this y.
I only get to see the x.
What is my statistical
experiment?
Please help me.
So is it the real line?
My sample space--
is it the real line?
Sorry, who does not
know what this means?
I'm sorry.
OK.
So this is called an indicator.
So I read it as--
if I wrote well, that would
be one with a double bar.
You can also write
i if you prefer
if you don't feel like
writing one in double bars.
And it's one of say--
I'm going to write
it like that--
1 of a is equal to 1 if a
is true and 0 if a is false.
OK?
So that means that if y is
larger than 4, this thing is 1.
And if y is not larger
than 5, this thing is 0.
OK.
So that's called an indicator--
indicator function.
It was very useful to just
turn anything into a 0, 1.
So now that I'm here,
what is my sample space?
0, 1.
Well, whatever this
thing I did not tell you
was taking value with the
thing you should have--
if I end up telling you that
is taking value 6 or 7 that
would be your sample space, OK?
OK, so it takes values 0, 1.
And then what is the
probability here?
What should I write here?
What should you write
without even thinking?
Yeah.
So let's assume
there's two seconds
before the end of the exam.
You're going to write Bernoulli.
And that's where you're going
to start checking if I'm going
to give you extra time, OK?
So you write Bernoulli
without thinking,
because it's taking value 0, 1.
So you just write Bernoulli,
but you still have to tell me
what possible parameters
this thing is taking, right?
So I'm going to write it
p, because I don't know.
And then p take value--
OK, so sorry.
I could write it like that.
Right?
That would be perfectly
valid, but actually no more.
It's not any p.
The p is the probability
that an exponential lambda
is larger than 5.
And maybe I want to have
lambda as a parameter.
OK, so what I need to
actually compute is,
what is the probability
that y is larger than 5--
when y is this
exponential lambda,
which means that what
I need to compute
is the integral between
5 and infinity of--
what is it?
1 over lambda.
How did I define
it in this class?
Did I change it-- what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
right, right, right.
Yeah.
Lambda e to the minus
lambda x dx, right?
So that's what I
need to compute.
What is this?
Yeah, so what is the
value of this integral?
Can you take
appropriate measures?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: OK?
And again, you can
cancel this, right?
So when I'm going to
integrate this guy,
those guys are going to cancel.
I'm going to get 0 for infinity.
I'm going to get
a 5 for this guy.
And well, I know it's going to
be positive number, so I'm not
really going to
bother with the signs,
because I know that's
what it should be.
OK, so I get e to
the minus 5 lambda.
And so that means that I can
actually write this like that--
and now parametrize this
thing by lambda positive.
OK?
So what I did here is I changed
the parametrization from p
to lambda.
Why?
Well, because maybe if I
know this is happening,
maybe I am actually
interested in reporting lambda
to MBTA, for example.
Maybe I'm actually trying to
estimate 1 over lambda, so
that I know it is--
well, lambda is
actually the intensity
of arrival of my
Poisson process, right?
I have a Poisson process.
That's how my trains
are coming in.
And so I'm interested in lambda.
So I will parametrize
things by lambda.
So the thing I get is lambda.
You can play with this, right?
I mean, I could parametrize
this by 1 over lambda
and put 1 over lambda
here if I want it.
But you know, the
context of your problem
will tell you exactly
how to parametrize this.
OK?
So what else did I
want to tell you?
OK, let's do a final one.
By the way, are you guys OK
with Poisson exponential,
Bernoulli's--
I don't know, binomial, normal--
all these things.
I'm not going to go
back to it, but I'm
going to use them heavily.
So just spend five
minutes on Wikipedia
if you forgot about
what those things are.
Usually, you must have seen them
the in your probability class.
So they should not
be a crazy name.
And again, I'm
not expecting you.
I don't remember what the
density of an exponential is.
So it would be
pretty unfair of me
to actually ask you to
remember what it is.
Even for the Gaussian,
I don't expect
you to remember what it is.
But I want you to remember that
if I add 5 to a Gaussian, then
I have a Gaussian with me and
mu plus 5 if I multiply it
by something, right?
You need to know how to
operate those things.
But knowing
complicated densities
is definitely not
part of the game.
OK?
So let's do a final one.
I don't know what
number I have now.
I'm going to just do uniform.
That's another one.
Everybody knows what uniform is?
So it's uniform, right?
So I'm going to have x,
which my observations are
going to be uniform on the
interval 0 theta, right?
So if I want to define
a uniform distribution
for a random variable, I have
to tell you which interval
or which set I want
it to be uniform on.
And so here I'm telling you
is the interval 0 theta.
And so what is going
to be my sample space?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I'm sorry?
0 to theta.
And then what is my
probability distribution?
My family of parameters?
So well, I can write
it like this, right?
Uniform theta, right?
And theta let's say is positive.
Can somebody tell me what's
wrong with what I wrote?
This makes no sense.
Tell me why.
Yeah?
Yeah, this set depends on theta,
and why is that a problem?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
There is no theta.
Right now, there's
the families of theta.
Which one did you pick here?
Right, this is just something
that's indexed by theta,
but I could have very well
written it as, you know,
just not being
Greek for a second,
I could have just written
this as t rather than theta.
That would be the same thing.
And then what the hell is theta?
There's no such thing as theta.
We don't know what
the parameter is.
This parameter should
move with everyone.
And so that means
that I actually am not
allowed to pick this theta.
I'm actually-- just for
the reason that there is no
parameter to put
on the left side--
there should not be, right?
So you just said, well, there's
a problem because the parameter
is on the left-hand side.
But there's not
even a parameter.
I'm describing the family
of possible parameters.
There is no one that you
can actually plug it in.
So this should really be 1.
And I'm going to
go back to writing
this as theta because
that's pretty standard.
Is that clear for everyone.
I cannot just pick one and put
it in there and just take the--
before I run my experiments,
I could potentially
get numbers that are
all the way up to 1,
because I don't know what theta
is going to be ahead of time.
Now, if somebody
promised to me that theta
was going to be less
than 0.5, that would be--
sorry, why do I put 1 here?
I could put theta
between 0 and 1.
But if somebody is going
to promise me, for example,
if theta is going
to be less than 1,
then you expect to put 0, 1.
All right?
Is that clear?
OK, so now you know how
to answer the question--
what is the statistical model?
And again, within the
scope of this class,
you will not be asked to just
come up with a model right that
will just tell you.
Poisson would be probably
be a good idea here.
And then you would just have
to trust me that indeed it
would be a good idea.
All right, so what I started
talking about 20 minutes ago--
so it's definitely
ahead of myself
is the notion-- so
that's when I was
talking about well-specified.
Remember, well-specified says
that the true distribution
is one of the distributions
in this parametric families
of distribution.
The true distribution
of my siblings
is actually a Poisson
with some parameters.
And all I need to figure out
is what this parameter is.
When I started saying
that, I said, well,
but then that
could be that there
are several parameters
that give me
the same distribution, right?
It could be the case that
Poisson 5 and Poisson 17
are exactly the same
distributions when
I started putting those numbers
in the formula which I erased,
OK?
So it could be the case that two
different numbers would give me
exactly the same probabilities.
And in this case, we see that
the model is not identifiable.
I mean, the parameter
is not identifiable.
I cannot identify the parameter,
even if you actually gave me
an infinite amount of data,
which means that I could
actually estimate
exactly the PMF.
I might not be able to go
back, because there would
be several candidates,
and I would not
be able to tell you which one
it was in the first place.
OK?
So what we want is
that this function--
theta maps to p
theta is injective.
And that really can be fancy.
What I really mean
is that if theta
is different from theta
prime, then p of theta
is different from
p of theta prime.
Or, if you prefer to think about
the contrapositive of this,
this is the same as saying
that if p theta gives me
the same distribution
as theta prime,
then that implies
that theta must
be equal to the theta prime.
The logic of those two
things are equivalent, right?
So that's what this means.
So this is-- we say that the
parameter is identifiable
or identified-- it
doesn't really matter--
in this model.
And this is something
we're going to want.
OK?
So in all the examples
that I gave you,
those parameters are
completely identified.
Right?
If I tell you--
I mean, if those things
are in probability box,
it means that they were
probably thought through, right?
So when I say
exponential lambda,
I'm really talking about one
specific distribution and not--
there's not another
lambda going to give you
exactly the same distribution.
OK so that was the case.
And you can check that,
but it's a little annoying.
So I would probably not do it.
But rather than doing
this, let me just
give you some examples where
it would not be the case.
Again, here's an
example, if I take xi--
so now I'm back to just using
this indicator function--
but now for a Gaussian.
So what I observe is
x is the indicator
that y is, what did we say?
Positive.
OK?
So this is a Bernoulli
random variable, right?
And it has some parameter p.
But p now is going
to depend-- sorry,
and here y is n mu sigma square.
So the p, the probability
that this thing is positive,
is actually--
I don't think I put the 0.
Oh, yeah, because I have mu.
OK, so this distribution--
this p the probability
that it's positive
is just the probably
that some Gaussian is positive.
And it will depend on
mu and sigma, right?
Because if I draw a 0, and I
draw my Gaussian around mu,
then the probability of
this Bernoulli being 1
is really the area
under the curve here.
Right?
And this thing-- well,
if mu is very large,
it's going to become very large.
If mu is very small, it's
going to become very small.
And if sigma changes, it's
also going to effect--
is that clear for everyone?
But we can actually
compute this, right?
So the parameter p that
I'm looking for here
as a function of mu
and sigma is simply
the probability that
some y is non-negative,
which is the probability that
y minus mu divided by sigma
is larger than minus
mu divided by sigma.
But when you study probability,
is that some operation you
were used to making?
Removing the mean and dividing
by the standard deviation?
What is the effect of
doing that on the Gaussian
random variable?
Yeah, so you
normalize it, right?
And you standardize it.
You make it a standard Gaussian.
You remove the mean.
The mean 0 is Gaussian.
And you remove the variance
for it to become 1.
So when you have a
Gaussian, remove the mean
and divide by the
standard deviation,
it becomes a standard Gaussian--
which this thing has
n , 0, 1 distribution,
which is the one you can read
the quintiles of at the end
of the book.
Right?
And that's exactly what we did.
OK?
So now you have the probability
that some standard Gaussian
exceeds negative mu
over sigma, which
I can write in terms of
the cumulative distribution
function, capital phi--
like we did in
the first lecture.
So if I do this cumulative
distribution function,
what is this probability
in terms of phi?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Well,
that's what your name tag says.
1 minus--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIPPE RIGOLLET:
1 minus mu of sigma.
What happens with phi in our--
do you think I
defined this for fun?
1 minus phi of mu
over sigma, right?
Right?
Because this is 1
minus the probability
that it's less than this.
And this is exactly
the definition
of the cumulative
distribution function.
So in particular, this thing
only depends on mu over sigma.
Agreed?
So in particular, if I
had 2 mu over 2 sigma,
p would remain unchanged.
If I have 12 mu over
12 sigma, this thing
would remain
unchanged, which means
that p does not
change if I scale mu
and sigma by the same factor.
So there's no way just
by observing x, even
an infinite times, so that I can
actually get exactly what p is.
I'm never going to be able to
get mu and sigma separately.
All I'm going to be able
to get is mu over sigma.
So here, we say that mu sigma--
the parameter mu sigma--
or actually each of them
individually-- those guys--
they're not identifiable.
But the parameter mu over
sigma is identifiable.
So if I wanted to write a
statistical model in which
the parameter is identifiable--
I would write 0, 1 Bernoulli.
And then I would write 1
minus phi over mu over sigma.
And then I would
take two parameters,
which are mu and r and
sigma squared positive.
So let's write sigma positive.
Right?
No, this is not identifiable.
I cannot write those two guys
as being two things different.
Instead, what I want to write
is 0, 1, Bernoulli 1 minus--
and now my parameter--
I forgot this-- my
parameter is mu over sigma.
Can somebody tell me
where mu over sigma lives?
What values can this thing take?
Any real value, right?
OK, so now I've done this
definitely out of convenience,
right?
Because that was the only
thing I was able to identify--
the ratio of mu over sigma.
But it's still something
that has some meaning.
It's the normalized mean.
It really tells me what
the mean is compared
to the standard deviation.
So in some models, in reality,
in some real applications,
this actually might
have a good meaning.
It's just telling
me how big the mean
is compared to the standard
fluctuations of this model.
But I won't be able
to get more than that.
Agreed?
All right?
So now that we've set
a parametric model,
let's try to see what our
goals are going to be.
OK?
So now we have a sample
and a statistical model.
And we want to estimate
the parameter theta,
and I could say,
well, you know what?
I don't have time
for this analysis.
Collecting data is going
to take me a while.
So I'm just going to mmm--
and I'm going to say
that mu over sigma is 4.
And I'm just going
to give it to you.
And maybe you will
tell me, yeah,
it's not very good, right?
So we need some
measure of performance
of a given parameter.
We need to be able to evaluate
if eyeballing the problem
is worse than
actually collecting
a large amount of theta.
We need to know if even if I
come up with an estimator that
actually sort of uses
the data, does it
make an efficient
use of the data?
Would I actually need 10
times more observations
to achieve the same accuracy?
To be able to answer
these questions,
well, I need to define
what accuracy means.
And accuracy is something
that sort of makes sense.
It says, well, I want theta.
I have to be close to theta.
And the theta is
a random variable.
So I'm going to
have to understand
what it means for
a random variable
to be close to a
deterministic number.
And so, what is a
parameter estimator, right?
So I have an estimator, and I
said it's a random variable.
And the formal definition--
so an estimator is a measurable
function of the data.
So when I write
theta hat, and that
will typically be my notation
for an estimator, right?
I should really write
theta hat of x1 xn.
OK?
That's what an estimator is.
If you want to know
an estimator is,
this is a measurable
function of the data.
And it's actually also
known as a statistic.
And you know, if
you're interested in,
you know, I see every day
I think when I have like,
you know, a dinner
with normal people.
And they say I'm a statistician.
Oh, yeah, I really
like baseball.
And they talk to me
about batting averages.
That's not what I do.
But for them, that's
what it is, and that's
because in a way, that's
what a statistic is.
A batting average
is a statistic.
OK, and so here
are some examples.
You can take the average xn bar.
You can take the maximum
of your observation.
That's the statistics.
You can take the first one.
You can take the first
one plus log of 1
plus the absolute
value of the last one.
You can do whatever you want
that will be an estimator.
Some of them are
clearly going to be bad.
But that's still a statistic,
and you can do this.
Now, when I say
measurable, I always have--
so you know, graduate
students sometimes
ask me like, yeah, how do I know
if this estimator is measurable
or not.
And usually, my answer is,
well, if I give you data,
can you compute it.
And they say, yeah, I'm like,
well, then it's measurable.
That's a very good rule to
check if you can actually--
if something is
actually measurable.
When is this thing
non-measurable?
It's when it's
implicitly defined.
OK, and in
particular, the things
that give you problems are--
sup or inf.
Anybody knows what
a sup or an inf is?
It's like a max or a min.
But it's not always attained.
OK, so if I have x1.
So if I look at the
infimum of the function
f of x for x on the real
line and f of x, sorry,
let's say x on the 1 infinity.
And f of x is equal to 1 over x.
Right?
Then the infimum is
the smallest value
we can take except
that it doesn't really
take it at 0 right, because
1 over x is going to 0.
But it's never
really getting there.
So we just called the inf 0.
But it's not the value
that it ever takes.
And these things might actually
be complicated to compute.
And so that's when you
actually have problems, right?
When the limit is not--
you're not really quite
reaching the limit.
You won't have this problem in
general, but just so you know,
an estimator is not
really anything.
It has to actually
be measurable.
OK, so the first thing we
want to know I mentioned it--
so an estimator is a statistic
which does not depend on theta,
of course.
So if I give you the data, you
have to be able to compute it.
And that probably should not
require not knowing any known
parameters.
OK, so an estimator is
said to be consistent.
When my data-- when I collect
more and more data, this thing
is getting closer and closer
to the true parameter.
All right?
And we said that eyeballing and
saying that it's going to be 4
is not really something
that's probably
going to be consistent.
But they can have things
that are consistent
but that are converging to
theta at different speeds.
OK?
And we know also that
this is a random variable.
It converges to something.
And there might be
some different notions
of convergence that kick in.
And actually there are.
And we say that it's weakly
convergent if it converges
in probability and
strongly convergent
if it converges
almost [INAUDIBLE]..
OK?
And this is just vocabulary.
It won't make a big difference.
OK?
So we will typically say it's
consistent with any of the two.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Well, so
in parametric statistics,
it's actually a little
difficult to come up with.
But in non-parametric ones, I
could just say, if I had xi,
yi, and I know that yi is
f of xi plus noise s1i.
And I know that f belongs
to some class of function,
let's say--
[INAUDIBLE] class of smooth
functions-- it's massive.
And now, I'm going to actually
find the following estimator.
I'm going to take the average.
So I'm going to do
least squares, right?
So I just check.
I'm trying to minimize the
distance of each of my f of xi
to my yi.
And now, I want to find
the smallest of them.
So if I look at the infimum
here, then the question is--
so that could be--
well, that's not really
an estimator for f.
But it's an estimator for
the smallest possible value.
And so for example,
this is actually
an estimator for the
variance of sigma square.
This might not be attained,
and this might not
be measurable if f is massive?
All right, so that's the
infimum over some class f of x.
OK?
So those are all voice things
that are defined implicitly.
If it's an average, for example,
it's completely measurable.
OK?
Any other question?
OK, so we know that the first
thing we might want to check,
and that's definitely something
we want about estimators that
is consistent, because
all consistency tells
us is that just as I
collect more and more data,
my estimator is
going to get closer
and closer to the parameter.
There's other things
we can look at.
For each possible value
of n-- now, right now,
I have a finite number
of observations--
25.
And I want to know something
about my estimator.
The first thing I want to check
is maybe if in average, right?
So this is a random variable.
Is this random
variable in average
going to be close
to theta or not?
And so the difference
how far I am from theta
is actually called the bias.
So the bias of an estimator is
the expectation of theta hat
minus the value that I hope
it gets, which is theta.
If this thing is equal to 0, we
say that theta hat is unbiased.
And unbiased estimators
are things that people
are looking for in general.
The problem is that there's
lots of unbiased estimators.
And so it might be misleading
to look for unbiasedness
when that's not
really the only thing
you should be looking for.
OK, so what does it
mean to be unbiased?
Maybe for this
particular round of data
you collected, you're
actually pretty far
from the true estimator.
But one thing that actually--
what it means is that if I redid
this experiment over, and over,
and over again, and I averaged
all the values of my estimators
that I got, then this would
actually be the right--
the true parameter.
OK.
That's what it means.
If I were to repeat
this experiment,
in average, I would actually
get the right thing.
But you don't get to
repeat the experiment.
OK, just a remark
about estimators,
look at this estimator-- xn bar.
Right?
Think of the kiss example.
I'm looking at the average
of my observations.
And I want to know what the
expectation of this thing is.
OK?
Now, this guy is by
linearity of the expectation,
it is this, right?
But my data is
identically distributed.
So in particular, all the xi's
have the same expectation,
right?
Everybody agrees with this.
When it's identically
distributed,
they'll get the
same expectation.
So what it means is
that this guy's here--
they're all equal to
the expectation of x1.
Right?
So what it means is
that these guys--
I have the average
of the same number.
So this is actually
the expectation of x1.
OK?
And it's true.
In the kiss example, this was p.
And this is p--
the probability of
turning your head right.
OK?
So those two things
are the same.
In particular, that means
that xn bar and just x1
have the same bias.
So that should probably
illustrate to you
that bias is not something
that really is telling you
the entire picture, Right?
I can take only one
of my observations--
Bernoulli 0, 1.
This thing will
have the same bias
as if I average 1,000 of them.
But the bias is really telling
you where I am in average.
But it's really not telling me
what fluctuations I'm getting.
And so if you want to start
having fluctuations coming
into the picture,
we actually have
to look at the risk
or the quadratic risk
of the estimator.
And so the quadratic
risk is the finest--
the expectation of the square
distance between theta hat
and theta.
OK?
So let's look at this.
So the quadratic risk--
sometimes it's
denoted that people
call it the l2 risk of
theta hat, of course.
I'm sorry for maintaining
such an ugly board.
[INAUDIBLE] this stuff.
OK, so I look at
the square distance
between theta hat and theta.
This is still-- this is the
function of a random variable.
So it's a random
variable as well.
And now I'm looking at the
expectation of this guy.
That's the definition.
I claimed that when this
thing goes to 0, then
my estimator is actually
going to be consistent.
Everybody agrees with this?
So if it goes to zero as n
goes to infinity-- and here,
I don't need to tell you what
kind of convergence I have,
because this is just
the number, right?
It's an expectation.
So it's a regular, usual
calculus-style convergence.
Then that implies that theta hat
is actually weakly consistent.
What did I use to tell you this?
Yeah, this is the
convergence in l2.
This actually is
strictly equivalent.
This is by definition saying
that theta hat converges in l2
to theta.
And we know that
convergence in l2
implies convergence in
credibility to theta.
That was the picture.
We're going up.
And this is actually
equivalent to a consistency
by definition-- a
weak consistency.
OK, so this is actually
telling you a little more
because this guy here--
they are both unbiased.
Theta xn bar is unbiased.
X1 is unbiased.
But x1 is certainly
not consistent ,
because the more data I collect,
I'm not even doing anything
with it.
I'm just taking the first data
point you're giving to me.
So they're both unbiased.
But this one is not consistent.
And this one we'll see
is actually consistent.
xn bar is consistent.
And actually, we've
seen that last time.
And that's because of the?
What guarantees the fact
that xn bar is consistent?
AUDIENCE: The law
of large numbers.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: The law
of large numbers, right?
Actually, it's
strongly consistent
if you have a
strong [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, so just in the
last two minutes,
I want to tell you a little bit
about how this risk is linked
to see, quadratic
risk is equal to bias
squared plus the variance.
So let's see what
I mean by this?
So I'm going to forget
about the absolute values
that you have a square.
I don't really need them.
If theta hat was
unbiased, this thing
would be the expectation
of theta hat.
It might not be the case.
So let me see how I can actually
see-- put the bias in there.
Well, one way to
do this is to see
that this is equal to
the expectation of theta
hat minus the
expectation of theta hat,
plus the expectation of
theta hat minus theta.
OK?
I just removed the same
and added the same thing.
So I didn't change anything.
Now, this guy is my bias, right?
So now let me expand the square.
So what I get is the expectation
of the square of theta
hat minus its expectation.
I should put some
square brackets--
plus two times
the cross-product.
So the cross-product
is what expectation
of theta hat minus the
expectation of theta hat times
expectation of theta
hat minus theta.
And then I have the last square.
Expectation of theta
hat minus theta squared.
OK?
So square,
cross-products, square.
Everybody is with me?
now this guy here--
if you pay attention, this
thing is the expectation
of some random variable.
So it's a deterministic number.
Theta is the true parameter.
It's a deterministic number.
So what I can do is pull
out this entire thing out
of the expectation like this
and compute the expectation only
with respect to that part.
But what is the
expectation of this thing?
It's zero, right?
The expectation of theta
hat minus the expectation
of theta hat is 0.
So this entire thing is equal 0.
So now when I actually collect
back my quadratic terms--
my two squared terms
in this expansion--
what I get is that
the expectation
of theta hat minus
theta squared is
equal to the expectation of
theta hat minus expectation
of theta hat squared plus
the square of expectation
of theta hat minus theta.
Right?
So those are just the two--
the first and the last term
of the previous equality?
Now, here I have the
expectation of the square
of the difference
between a random variable
and its expectation.
This is otherwise known
as the variance, right?
So this is actually equal to
the variance of theta hat.
And well, this was the bias.
We already said that's there.
So this whole thing
is the bias square.
OK?
And hence the quadratic
term is the sum
of the variance and
the squared bias.
Why squared bias?
Well, because otherwise,
you would add dollars
in dollars squared.
So you need to add dollars
squared and dollars
squared so that this thing
is actually homogeneous.
So if x is in dollars, then
the bias is in dollars,
but the variance is
in dollars squared.
OK, and the square here
forced you to put everything
on the square scale.
All right, so what's nice is
that if the quadratic risk goes
to 0, then since I have the
sum of two positive terms,
both of them have to go to 0.
That means that my
variance is going to 0--
very little fluctuations.
And my bias is also going to 0,
which means that I'm actually
going to be on
target once I reduce
my fluctuations, because
it's one thing to reduce
the fluctuations.
But if I'm not on target,
it's an issue, right?
For example, the estimator for
the value 4 has no variance.
Every time I'm going to
repeat the experiments,
I'm going to get 4, 4, 4, 4--
variance is 0.
But the bias is bad.
The bias is 4 minus theta.
And if theta is far from 4,
that's not doing very well.
OK, so next week, we will--
we'll talk about what
is a good estimate--
how estimators
change if they have
high variance or low variance
or high bias and low bias.
And we'll talk about
confidence intervals as well.